bonjour philippe roddick merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
bonjour je vous en prie d'où vient cette
succès serbe alors que en france ça
patine un peu sur la vaccination
vous voyez c'est pas vraiment un miracle
c'est le fruit d'une politique étrangère
très bas on sait qui est qui est menée
dans le meilleur intérêt de du peuple
serbe
c'est le fruit du fait qu' on essaie
d'avoir de meilleures relations avec
hull ou west avec eux l'union européenne
avec les états unis mais en même temps
on fait tout de devoir de mes relations
avec la russie et la chine
en refusant à se joindre aux sanctions
de l'union européenne de bruxelles de
devaux shelton et on menant cette
politique qu'on peut qu'on peut appeler
vraiment une politique indépendante
qu'on a eus possibilité de deux
d'acheter des vaccins en même temps des
vaccins de pfizer astrazeneca et
spoutnik ce2 et si nos femmes je pense
que c'est
c'est le fruit de ça et rien d'autre
alors est ce que aujourd'hui la serbie
est devenue aussi pour ses pays voisins
finalement un lieu de tourisme vaccinale
avec toutes ces doses je pense que
c'était une décision très très bas de
notre gouvernement
on a une longue tradition de 2,2
d'altruisme si je peux dire ça déjà en
1875 je pense la croix la croix rouge
internationale
à vue les efforts humanitaires que
l'armée serbe a fait au moment où on
était en guerre avec la bulgarie et
aujourd'hui vous avez même une
inspection à l'inscription sur le sûr si
je peux dire est un majeur de la de la
croix rouge à genève où il a marqué sur
ce rayon humains comme les serbes l'ont
été en 1875
excusez moi si je me trompe de l'année
mecs c'était hors pauvres à la fin du
19e siècle alors on a eu un surplus à un
moment des vaccins soient zeneca qui qui
risque et d'expirer et on a on a utilisé
sa pour invité tous nos voisins de venir
à belgrade et de se vacciner en même
temps déjà à vendre on a vu qu'on avait
offert des quantités assez importantes à
nos voisins en premier rang à la bosnie
herzégovine monténégro la macédoine et
c'était 1 1
une action qui était de notre point de
vue c'est pas vraiment étrange
est ce que pour vous le vaccin est
devenu non pas une armée en tout cas un
outil diplomatique
oui on peut dire ça mais je pense que ce
serait un peu de comment dire un peu
injuste parce que c'est pas vraiment
utile diplomatique c'est aussi un décès
dans notre meilleur intérêt que nos
voisins ne soit pas en crise si nos
voisins sont pas sans ressources en
temps de crise et qu'elles n'ont pas des
moyens de ce que de combattre cette
maladie
nous aussi on est on compte danger même
si on est vaccinés
alors on a décidé de faire notre mieux
ça en même temps on a eu ça nous a
permis de faire un un succès
diplomatique mais c'est pas c'est pas
uniquement siens est-ce que comment est
ce que est ce que vous voyez le fait que
l'union européenne tire la langue
en ce moment avec sa stratégie vaccinale
c'est c'est compliqué et dans le même
temps bien refuse de se tourner ou vers
la russie ou vers la chine comment est
ce que vous vous vous l'observez d'abord
l'union europe 1 c'est un c'est un géant
ou bureaucratiques qu eux qui y ait de
sérieux problèmes d'adopter des
décisions rapides dans legrand au moment
où elles sont nécessaires et d'adopter
je dirais des décisions qui sont saines
la décision de jouer plutôt sur un sur
un plan géopolitique que politique et on
peut même dire idéologique
en dépit des de la santé de ses voisins
l'union européenne n'a pas n'a pas
montré sa meilleure phase on doit
rappeler nos spectateurs même que le
parlement européen il a adopté récemment
une résolution sur la serbie où ils
disent que la manière dont come back
dont la pandémie n'est pas la meilleure
et en même temps c'est la serbie qui a
le taux de 2 morts cavité eux le
pratiquant le plus bas en europe
chez nous le taux de mortalité du
colisée 0.9 % alors qu'en france c'est
je pense 2.2 en belgique son corpus et
même si on regarde sur sur la population
sur un rester sur le nombre de morts sur
musique sur un million d'habitants
la serbie est l'un des maires pays en
europe à côté de la russie de la galère
l'uchronie nous avons je pense 740 mort
sur un million d'habitants alors que la
france à 1300 et la belgique encore
pierce et 1995
ça montre en plus le pan que je sais
l'union européenne n'a pas ouvert un
nouveau revers aux pétales nouveaux lits
pour pour les malades alors que quand
servi en a ouvert deux ou trois hôpitaux
spécialisés pour la pour le combat du
collet de 19
même si notre situation économique n'est
pas aussi aisé que que c'est en france
ou en allemagne
oui oui pour sauver la consommation et
les servent aussi reste pour certains
réticents à la vaccination le chef de
l'exécutif fait beaucoup d'efforts pour
justement et dire à la population serbe
de se faire vacciner 1
oui c'est vrai il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont skeptic parce que parce que ces
nouveaux vaccins sont d'un point de vue
peut-être laïque mais aussi à des
scientifiques qui le disent line in ils
n'ont pas été toujours assez recherchée
on n'est pas sûr de ce que ces vaccins
font est le meilleur exemple va faire
astrazeneca qui qui qui est suspendu
dans certains pays ensuite eu remise en
circulation etc
il ya un grand nombre de serbes qui sont
sceptiques mais c'est assez
compréhensible parce que les serres de
ronds appris à être sceptique envers les
médias envers les messages du
gouvernement mais aussi en converse
converse les messages qui nous arrive de
de l'ouest à cause de notre histoire
récente on a été démoniser prenant les
guerres en croatie en bosnie au kosovo
et les gens beaucoup de gens ne font pas
confiance on ne compte pas comme une
vérité absolue ce qu'on me dit sur la
télévision
merci beaucoup philippe roddick d'avoir
répondu allocations ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl france je le rappelle
vous êtes rédacteur en chef adjoint du
magazine pk tu à belgrade